think dig dig dig dig whoa oh my god
going soaked in on that hand Wow welcome
back to the genuine podcast
why go and dig him take fan
we're back with another podcast this
episode's brought to you by me undies
look at all this festive me I mean
beautiful underwear I saw this print on
the bot the other day it's so festive
I'm rinsing right now guys get yourself
some holiday me andis right now they're
the sexiest underwear in town and you
know what if your day starts with
underwear and ends with underwear why
would you settle for anything less than
amazing
which is what Mandy says hmmm right now
you get 20% off your first order by
going to meet undies calm yeah Jenna
Julian ah look let's wear these at the
same time we'll be like thing 1 and
thing 2 so cute me and e1 Amanda - yeah
these are their holiday prints and they
are super festive so again I love these
legs yeah okay since I also this episode
is brought to you by nature box guys
nature box is no longer a monthly
subscription service now nature rocks
offers complete flexibility for members
who want to order whatever they want
whenever they want
GameChanger which is really awesome this
is probably one of my favorite acts that
baked blue corn tortilla chips which
I'll be very rudely snacking on
throughout the podcast all right now you
go to naturebox.com/tyler annejulien and
you get 50% first order really awesome
change from nature box so you don't have
to only get monthly subscriptions you
can get it how you want
Thank You Dora sponsor thank you sponsor
is OG sponsors yes they've been here
with us it been happen he'd been had
been here been here but alright so if
you remember I know you've seen the
title this podcast but if you remember
we played a game called super fight
where you got a card and it gave you a
character or a person and then you had
to argue your position and some powers
need to argue why your person would be
the other person
person's person character and Julian got
the card Gandhi and I said well first of
all Gandhi's dead so you already loose
that was
argument to which Julian responded is he
dead I don't know is he and then he
looked it up and just quickly glanced
because you know we're in the podcast
sometimes it's not like you're sitting
here reading Wikipedia you glanced at it
and it's at age 78 so Julian are you
that Gandhi was alive and we sat here
and had this moment of well oh well I
guess he's alive mine [ __ ] I guess he's
alive but Gandhi is super dead party but
we thought it would be funny if I
compiled the list of people because
we've done two podcasts where Julian's
we know that Julian sucks at celebrity
trivia which is serrocold
no one's laughing at you we're all
laughing with I agree it's funny and
also some of these people like I to
Google how old they are when they died
if they're alive how old they are fair
lives and I wouldn't know a lot of this
stuff had I not just googled it you mean
yeah but I made a master list of people
and we're going to play dead or alive
are you ready Julia let's get it on okay
so here's how it's gonna work yeah let
me tell you the person you're gonna tell
me if they're dead or alive if they're
alive how old they are if they're dead
how old they were or when they died I
have to say how they died I mean I don't
know the answer to all of that okay so
no but you could and as you get their
age you don't have to but say you know
so say I say a Bette Midler and you're
like she's alive
tell me how old you think she is or if
she's dead tell me when she died and how
old she was when she journalist no okay
good cuz I didn't know that alright
let's get going
alright so this it's a mix of
celebrities historical figures that kind
of thing
are you excited Julianne to play
Dead or Alive no okay so since I believe
you're talking about Mahatma Gandhi the
first person on this list is Indira
Gandhi
what is Indira Gandhi dead or alive the
only other Gani that's famous Gandhi
dead that is correct
her is endearing Gandhi a boy or a girl
girl she is a girl how old was she when
she died when she died
61 when she died at the end of her life
that's close
she's 6 she was 66 she died in 1984 she
was the Prime Minister of India all
right I knew all of that sir
okay next person Julien is Patti LaBelle
dead or alive varial you know that was
why you know that one I watch your
cooking show where she has these giant
eyes fake nails and she's like mashing
crab cakes together oh it's amazing and
it's incredible yeah Pat about Queen
how old do you think Patti LaBelle is 58
has incorrect Patti LaBelle 72 years old
Wow yeah Patti LaBelle is 72 [ __ ] yeah
okay I see you Patti that's why it's
also even funnier that she has six inch
long nails
yeah there's bicha Stephanie - she seems
senile that makes sense now
all right Julien oh my god how many
names you have do you know offset again
uh one two three four you have to come
right now seven eight nine ten until 30
foot their table about 15 per page and
there's four pages okay let's get moving
Julien is george w bush dead or alive
really dead or alive george w bush he's
alive
how old is he 63 he's 70 okay George HW
Bush his father dead or alive dead when
did he die in how old died in 2007
mm-hmm when he was I don't know 90
he's alive and he's 92 years old that's
all okay that's all I got the first time
there's one wrong okay
Amelia Earhart she's still out there
she's so fly in the sky
she just keeps refueling refueling this
guy all right P him peace
she died in 1951 how old was she when
she died 29 those aren't the worst
guesses she died July 2nd 1937 she was
30 hard day for me 39 years old
39 39 I was off with that 39 years old
auntie Amelia we will always remember
her as the best aunt the best of all
time of all time still watching us from
her plane what if there was a thing like
that you could fly forever as long as
you kept refueling like people just live
in the air
yeah just admitting so much carbon into
the yeah atmosphere no yeah totally
that's that's right
I'd be tight yeah that's what she's
doing that's what Amelia hurts me hmm oh
she's dead though wait so is she dead
trillion already said I already answered
the question
moving on all right Judy Garland dead or
alive she the author she is not an
author don't look at my mother okay can
you literally never say that to me
because I'm not going to cheat all right
is deep okay who is Judy Garland oh
that's not a game we're playing okay
okay fair enough not kissing oh boy okay
okay she's she's dead unfortunately when
did she die you know illegal don't wake
me ask 1955 and how old was she when she
died
78 hmm Judy Garland was the star of The
Wizard of Oz yeah the one of the
slippers the one with the slippers she
died in
wait that's not right is it I wrote 1920
to age 47 that's that seems that might
have been ago
that's when she was born maybe but she
died oh my god Gillian are you really
gonna eat corn chips
what no um she was 48 Eric no sorry
47 when she died 47 I'm trying to think
of the author that you thought Judy
Garland I think you have Judy Blume no
I'm thinking of someone else if she was
born in 1922 she died in 1969
Jane Garland is that a thing you know I
don't know Julian what no ASMR eating
corn tips okay all right the next person
is Larry King dead or alive Larry King
is alive he's 83 oh my god Murray yes
welcome to the Julianne sure exactly 83
years old yeah Wow I'm like honestly
really impressed oh yeah the chances of
you getting any of these perfectly right
is not high
all right let's while some fools okay
Julian Whitney Houston dead or alive
dead
when did she die how old was she she
died four years ago I remember like it
was yesterday it was four years ago
right
it actually was yeah how old is she's 47
she's 48 she died February 11 2012 hey
just for he all right this is getting a
little weird oh why am I so good at this
oh boy here we go all right Whitney
Houston's daughter Bobbi Kristina Brown
dead or alive stop [ __ ] eating play
the game
my village is dead the answer the
question is alive
keep going how old is she daughter yeah
24 Bobbi Kristina Brown is dead and
she's 22 died that happened recently
right yeah in the bathtub hmm that's
right that's what's sad this game is
meant is absolutely no disrespect but it
is fun it's fun but we're not laughing
at their death they're laughing at my
lack of knowledge of everything because
I'm dumb stop it we're not some fun game
stop eating chips Tim really this is too
much ASMR chip eating stew have done
sorry
Thank You bothers a date I'm gonna take
that nature box away from you Pablo
Picasso dead or alive he is dead his so
dead he died at age 60 to 70 years ago
give me a year 1944 she died April 8th
1973 he was 91 years old very close
relation he was dead
you got that part right you had a most
important part right mhm mm-hmm he's
good at art he was he was great at night
I love how we get taught who was good at
art like what if you just want to scour
old artists and be like dude this one
guy though he was off the chain or this
guy who got so much recognition was
lowkey trash low-key trash overrated
overhyped
low-key garbage fan her all right bill
gates what did her a lot how old is he
sir reason he is 61 years old oh he's
looking good for 60 no he's looking bad
for 61 Julie 37 parsy 61 he looks older
than he is he's younger than my mom he
doesn't look 61 how old does he look 77
dan looks like all that all those peanut
billionaires windows is
I'm out windows is stretching low I mean
it stresses everyone out and we didn't
invent it yeah he sleeps at night and it
goes okay that's the one thing on this
most from vine this does windows that
attend Oh Ronald Reagan dead or alive
Ronald Reagan is dead how old was he
when did he die
51 when did he die some time ago
come on what when did he die some time
ago 15 you know I was 2 years ago 30
years ago 20 years ago he is dead you
got that part right
yeah good for you June 5th 2004 he was
93 when he died I was close okay close
hey all right
Diana Ross do you know who that is what
do you know who Diana Ross's yeah who is
she she's a female singer oh yeah she is
she's dead how old was she when she died
70 what year 1999 okay she's alive and
she's 72 she just got a freedom medal
from President Barack Obama the other
day
Oh how'd that go it was good it's good
thing she's ha ha I love this game
okay okay the Dalai Lama Dead or Alive
Dalai Lama someone's running a Twitter
account with that name not be the guy on
Iran 11 say dad died in 1966 he's alive
and he's 81
uh well somebody's doing we don't know
okay all right sure
Regis Philbin Dead or Alive
we just film it is alive how old is he
oh he did so you know do you know where
you just fell been in yeah is the news
guy no I mean you're close but not uh
actor mmm and no we just we just from
Regis and Kelly
yeah redistributed Kelly alive you're so
proud of yourself he's 85 when I say
like 60 something I wasn't 7 mm yes sir
that's at 85 he's alive he's a defense
how's he doing he's good I think he on
Regis and Kelly know that show is zero
[ __ ] it has not happened in a long time
that show so it just went on without him
yeah is it Michael and Kelly no even
Michael left Kelly and Kelly Kelly yeah
they keep cycling in hosts I guess I
don't watch it but I do read blind
gossip oh you do do you dude
um he also hosts said Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire you remember that show
yeah and done a lot of other stuff he's
Regis Regis you just John F Kennedy who
dead assassinated um 40 years ago very
Fiat 45 what year 1973 how old was he
when he debt a 45 50 you're very close
he died 9 May 29 1963
he's 846 close yeah good one all right
Lucille Ball
Oh Dead or Alive Julian who is Lucille
Ball
the one in um you know who is Lucille
volvulus that's a short for Lucille
Baldwin her that's her oh man no he's an
actress yes she was on I Love Lucy yes
yes you did know who she was
she is dead how dead like sixty years
ago okay give me a gear Oh 1959 how old
1969 sorry she died in 1979 how old is
she she uh 1979 and she was 93
she died in uh April 26 1989 to 792 go
up ten more years already miss her okay
you already miss her we all do she was
pretty great Andy Warhol you got a 50-50
chance that are alive Jillian Judy was
who's Annie was an artist
oh yeah anyone she's dead
how old and when he died when he was 60
1960 he died February 22nd 1987 he was
58 hey close you have aged almost uh
pretty close 87 okay
MC Hammer Dead or Alive
alive how old is he 74 he's alive and he
is 54 I was close you're close Nelson
Mandela
Dead or Alive - we can't chill out here
on this one because I think he died
recently and did he not he's dead right
that's this is the game I can't you guys
- guys when he was um 84 when like five
years ago so you're not gonna give me a
year 2010 he died December 5th 2013 he
was 95 95 95 good for him
what a life but he was also that
conspiracy theory the Mandela effect
that people thought he died much earlier
than he did that's where the Mandela
name comes from in the Mandela effect
actually I don't know but maybe no they
spelled differently in dollar no no
[ __ ] whatever you know I don't know
so he had in 2013 he was 95 yeah okay
Elvis Presley Julianne dead or alive
dead when did he die how old he died
when he was 33 in 1976 damn 1977 he was
42 I was close good one all right Al
Gore dead or alive he's alive
how old is Al Gore 61 he's 68 okay let's
fake it Frank Sinatra dead or alive dead
come on he died when he was 50 go on in
1988 he died when he was 83 in 1998 okay
so it wasn't really close I just got
that he was dead is Madonna Dead or
Alive
I loved how old is she
59 damn uh she's 58 oh [ __ ]
you got that one pretty close mmm okay
draw that one okay mother Teresa dad or
a lot do you know how mother teresa's
yeah she's dead well that's the game
we're playing
stop looking I'm not looking all right
how old and when are you gonna make me
ask you every time yeah she was 60 and
she died is this like a trick question
didn't she die like hundreds and
hundreds of years ago I'm not answering
that can she die and 1871 and how old is
she
55 something she died September 5th 1997
she was 87 she died before she was born
actually that was a weird trick question
why cuz her name has mother in it yeah
that's unfair oh I can test that okay
Stephen Hawking dead or alive alive how
old is he a three he's 74 I'm gripped
close enough Barbra Streisand
it's good question
alright ah Barbra Streisand is Barbra
Streisand data a lot who is Barbra
Streisand releasing her yes
she's live 78 she is alive she's 7400
Good King Julian Princess Diana Dead or
Alive
who's this I'm not gonna answer that
don't eat oh my god stop um Princess
Diana
Dead or Alive he's alive she's 83 where
did she live England she's dead
she died in 1997 she was 36 years old
did you live in England oh yes it was it
was a terrible tragedy she died in a car
accident
oh I'm sorry it's okay we're not
offended my prayers and thoughts are
with her family
mmm thank you for those they weren't for
you you don't remember that when that I
guess you were born in what 9205 yeah it
was like a big big big deal what can you
explain what happened yeah she got in a
car accident in a tunnel and died
immediately yeah well I think I don't
know don't quote me on that but it was a
big thing there's a lot of conspiracy
theories around it no it's really yeah
it was a big deal well you know the song
candle in the wind by Elton John yes
House another song ten thousand candles
the wind by Andy in Parks and Rec okay
totally not related exactly related I've
never seen that so I don't know what
you're talking about worried right now
no please don't please don't
I'm begging you don't tell me how you
really feel please he wrote that song
for it to stay into them okay Janet
Jackson a lot how old is she
fifty-two she's 51 his friend Steve Jobs
dead he died he was 66 when did he die
four years ago 2012 honey died 2011 he's
56 because well I guess 60 something 66
yeah Paltrow Dead or Alive 54 she's 44
and now insulted sorry Glenn Albert
Einstein he's dead and he died in 1953
when he was 48 he died in 1955 when he
was 76 infants because 48 what is wrong
he was he was way out of them for the a
on it yeah you seen pictures yeah like
what am I thinking
48 Haggard 448 yeah all right well
utilize studying okay you wanna take a
break with you naturebox Oh like a food
break I'm just I'm just chillin mmm
Cedar Rapids where we got keep going by
the Barbara Walters who's that
I'm not gonna answer that question two
guys none of those she's a news lady and
she's dead she died in 2006 and she was
69
she's alive she's 87 are you sure you
should check on that okay sorry sorry
barb Alexander Graham Bell gender a lot
dad died in 1951 at the age of 63 she
died didn't 1922 Oh 75 do you know what
he did Alexander Graham Bell yeah what
do you know what Alexander Graham Bell
dude yeah we don't know that you can say
it if it makes you feel better but he
did the what did you watch no not so
much
the Graham no damn prize no the cream
fries good rapper no Cedar Rapids he
invented Cedar Rapids he mented the Bell
he invented the ruler no no I'm just
doing this for you playing the game what
it what did he invent but what did he
bet the phone yeah didn't I say that
like an hour ago when I was like bell
ringing hello Alex was Oprah Winfrey
Dead or Alive
she's so alive she is so alive
general cheese ah Oprah well I watched
super soul Sunday and it's been 7,000
Sundays now she's 61 she's 62 yes
because all right there Marilyn Monroe
dead her left she died when she was 44
in 1980 80 mm okay
she died August 5th 1962 she was 36 was
cause of age 36
what are you doing you closed my laptop
boy yeah that's so sad she's 30 she's
six years old
right now sad that is sad that's morbid
to think about Elizabeth Taylor Dadar
listen with Taylor I mean is anyone
really dead Donna don't dance around it
it she deadly if she's at Elizabeth
Taylor's dead she's dead unfortunately
it's over go on she died in 2000 she was
mm all right B yes Taylor - mm damn she
a wizard
she died in 2011 she was 79 Oh 79 going
on
mm that was disrespectful I apologize
for that
Wow I'm offended all right Stephen King
Stephen King is dead he was an author
when did he die in hole 18 no he he died
when he was he died when he was 68 in
1999 okay he's alive
guess how old he is where's he been I
have nine that's how he wasn't he died
no he is alive but that's what I guess
his death age was all right he know he's
alive well you better be god I was so
like so wrong but it just said that
I was really hoping you were gonna go
with that he died in eighteen something
real I know he didn't die in eighteen
something else it's just thinking about
stuff all right
Donatella Versace Dead or Alive
so really quickly what you don't know
who Donatella Versace is is that the
person who that Versace not invented is
there named after then Versace's named
after them the family Oh Ted died like
thirty years ago in 1917 or a woman
that's not a gamer Donatella Versace
Donna tell us a girl mm-hmm
she died in 1977 how old is she when she
ate she's alive she's 61 you don't know
who that is
she like long blonde hair big big lips
dark smoky eye all the times she showed
me a picture of her I probably would
recognize it as I've probably seen it
before but no I don't know really the
scope of my brain does not extend that
far here look at this face let me
minimize my thing tell me if you've ever
seen this person before
oh yeah no hooded that's Donatella
yeah that's time to tell her she Gooden
what do you mean is she good what does
that mean that's for physical health is
she good she is he okay think she's all
right I mean you have to ask a lot of
work done get a lot of work done it's
her face and her body her choice it's
not all hers Oh God
all right you ready yeah Franklin D
Roosevelt deader lub-dub died in 1938 he
was 60 she died
1945 he was 63 oh so that's not bad that
could have been that was a really good
guess thank you that's good all right
Michael Jordan alive
how old is he
you know how this game works um he's 53
you're exactly right we've gotten to
exactly right oh my god Joseph okay all
right yeah all right Julian this is me
air jordan michael kiske shear dead Orla
girl now that we know who share is
Rachel tell us tell us how again how you
remember who shares when I say who is
share she's from stuck on you she's
alive
how old is she 55 she's 70 yes she is
alive
oh girl you look over 70 yeah really
though she's 70 yeah the [ __ ] yeah it's
pretty wild she's rage all right oh well
that will move that make her and stuck
on you like 60 69 72
she probably 72 and stuck on you what a
great year for her top is she older then
than she is now she said yes sir though
she aged to that grade six years ago
she's actually a vampire name is Cher so
yeah she was she was at least like 64
when she made that smash hit of her
lifetime probably the most accomplished
offense she's done that movie
I feel like I've only seen a part of
stuck on you I've never seen that we
need to sit down we're stuck on you why
made me watch my best friend's wedding
which I'm sorry a movie is subpar and if
you made me watch that I get to make you
watch stuck on you it's a great movie
okay Matt Damon Greg Kinnear wonderful
together wonderful together now Streep's
even in it
yeah but it's meta she's Meryl Streep in
it I have to get Meryl Streep because
they shot on Martha's Vineyard and she's
got some ties there I guess that makes
sense it's a wonderful movie Ava Mendez
I think isn't it yeah Eva Mendes um yeah
the opening scene is opens up on a tight
shot of them inside criminal justice
crap movies okay yeah I try them inside
there a problem
judge Li in podcast this is the episode
where Julian shot-for-shot describes the
movie stuck on Enoch damn good out of
the shower and they're off for a jog and
they're jogging along next to each other
together tight attached yep and Greg
Kinnear is jogging and he says hi to
this girl so he starts turning around as
they jog and he's like chatting her up
and Matt Damon's like we gotta make time
and he's like no chatting her up more
and then but they stuck together how was
one of them doing one thing cuz he's
like Trent let me shine around ruzek
turn around
oh he's like a bit big and she's like
super having it because he's great with
the ladies not Dana and on the other
hand he's more of like a he's more of
you know a little introverted outside of
then they go home shower back to their
wood job they're flipping burgers they
have this system where one of them's
cutting stuff up and they flip it over
and the other guy catches any stacks the
burger it's great great scene and uh and
so you know works going pretty well
but then all of a sudden this guy comes
in he's really upset with his with his
burger and he he's like hey man this is
bad burger is not what I wanted and then
they deal with him like the school bully
he is and they get him out of there
because his paintings were in a bunch
and his panties were not me undies oh my
god Julia
is a real product that is I did not lie
that is exactly exactly of the movie
guys I swear to God he did not just do
that
I didn't tell a single lie that's
exactly how it goes but he wasn't
wearing Andy's cuz he would have been
way happier if he was guys you can get
yourself some wonderful me I knees right
now I am like you could never thought
way that you just did that
sis of a movie stuck on you
and segwayed into me undies me and these
are amazing we guys we live in a world
we're putting on a new pair of underwear
isn't just fresh you're stepping into a
better day okay if you think about it
you start your day by putting on your
underwear and you the nu a by taking
them off so why not have it be the best
the best is mayonese right now they're
producing the most comfortable underwear
you've ever experienced friends at me
Andy sent us a bunch of Paris these are
the holiday pairs right now guys try
them on and you'll understand this is
three times softer than cotton three
times
it's made of modal fabric and it just it
makes your bottom incredibly happy and
what's exciting about me and these is
that they're always coming out with
awesome new designs try them if they're
not the most comfortable best feeling
underwear you've ever read you've ever
put on your your bottom your whole life
you your first pair for free alright
that's their guarantee right now you go
to me and ease comm slash Jenna Julianne
and you get 20% off your order of
wonderful wonderful underwear I'm
currently wearing me undies and I show
them awful all the time me knees are
wonderful and you guys should get a pair
so thank you me Andes for sponsoring us
which one do you like the most like the
polka-dots
I like those Christmas lights oh these
yeah that's cool that'll be cool they
lit up though that'd be probably
dangerous and be tying our other sponsor
this week is naturebox guys order any
snacks you want any amount any time now
because nature box is no longer just a
monthly subscription service they offer
complete flexibility for members to
order whatever they want whenever they
want so if it were me I would just be
like hey can you ship like an entire
truck full of baked bean corn tortilla
chips so I can eat them on my podcast
like every day and they'd be like yeah
sure fam all good so if you go to nature
box.com slash angeling you get 50% of
your first order and it is truly truly
wonderful guys there's so many different
snacks they have sweet snacks savory
snacks and they are
made from real food and you don't have
to feel guilty when you're snacking on
okay and the size they're delicious
they have everything you might want and
I'm being forced to not eat these right
now but this is kind of tortured because
they're really really good and why go to
the grocery store when you can plan your
snacks ahead of time and get them
delivered to you I go to the grocery
store nature boxes are here for you and
you know what guys if you are if you you
know we're hesitant log into nature box
or for now you can do it all the car you
and a snacks you want when you want you
can dictate everything which is awesome
you know I mean you can customize
everything about it and have some
delight with nature box right now but a
nature box are complex Angelina she was
not frightful delightful I cannot
believe you just did that
can I continue telling the story go
ahead keep going so work ends right they
knock this guy out they're like hey you
gotta get out of our restaurant is for
happiness only so he leaves and then
works over and everyone's like you got
to get to the game like oh we gotta get
to the coin game they're on a hockey
team they play goalie together they are
goalie that's cheating and they take us
at our whole pocket know the entire net
there's nowhere to score they just stand
there
that's going to people and so they
they're the town heroes because they're
the best goalie no one can score on them
and then you know and then the life
happens and they you know Greg Kinnear
has dreams to be an actor and Matt Damon
just wants to be a small-town
short-order cook at that burger joint
and then so they leave they leave each
other how do they leave each other
I see movie find out no tell me I'm not
I'm not ruining the movie it's great
movie you should watch it oh wait but I
thought that they shared a pair of legs
no no they it's like two people who are
attached at the side that's that's
[ __ ] stupid it's not stupid it's like
the best movie of all time top five
coming from the person who thinks the
best film of all time is Big Daddy
I was Adam Sandler every said it was the
best daddy
I never said his best film all time I
said it's like one of my favorite movies
anytime someone asks you what's your
favorite movie ever you go Big Daddy
that's one of them
sorry I love that movie and the kid's
name is Julian [ __ ] out of here you
realize that that's not my best friend's
wedding the move at least is not my
daughter Larry wedding the cobbler you
and I both watch the cop yeah well
Sandra Bullock made some crap too so I'm
not going to start talking about her
wait what is Sandra Bullock have to do
my best friend's wedding she's the one
getting married Julia Roberts Julianne
uh stop I'm not going to be for me no
Charlie no no you know it's Julia
Roberts don't even troll me I'm not
charlie is the blonde girl in that movie
who's Kimmie I don't even know what you
just said at me what is what is that
movie and who's Kimmie and what I don't
know what that is Kimmie and my best
friend's wedding it's Sandra Bullock
who's the blonde girl I don't remember
what why was that she's not a main
character easily what's the movie about
Julien know that she's getting married
and getting married Kimmy's getting
married she was getting married to Julia
Roberts's ex-boyfriends the blonde
actress and that movie I don't know in
Affairs who Cameron Diaz Oh totally yeah
yeah so she's getting married to see how
hard this is to keep track a better
movie would just be stuck on you because
it's it's got all the character
development and without any of the
confusion how do they go come apart they
have surgery and then they don't know
how to live they like walk in opposite
directions and they keep falling over
are you are you serious yes you keep
they walk out of the hospital standing
on that wheelchair and then they both
walk and fall into the bushes
it's a really classic moment in cinema
is it meant to be like a funny movie of
course it's a comedy
is it a comment it's a comedy it's not
it's a comedy ask Cher okay it's like
her shining moment okay what
shares role in the movie she's sure
she's herself yeah why are they meeting
all these company Hollywood he wants to
be an actor but I thought they shot it
in Martha's Vineyard they leave Martha's
Vineyard because Greg Kinnear wants to
be an actor so they go to Hollywood to
pursue his dream oh you're calling
Martha's Vineyard small town what yeah
it's like one of the richest places in
the country it's still a small town it's
physically a small town okay so they're
stuck on each other and [ __ ] loaded
is what you're saying
no they're not loaded if they were
loaded why are they be short-order cooks
that doesn't make sense
not everyone who lives in Martha's
Vineyard is loaded boy where do they
live New England in Martha's Vineyard
that's yes um where do they live in a
house in Martha's Vineyard a tiny
apartment in a tiny apartment yeah are
you lying to me I think as an opponent I
want to watch this movie and look at
their house no no watch I believe you're
gonna poke holes in the laptop you get
to watch it and enjoy it just like real
estate my best friend's wedding and
enjoyed that
absolutely subpar movie a movie is great
subparts
wonderful so I'm supposed to just like
root against a happy wedding for a whole
two hours wow what a fun movie
experience no not she doesn't marry him
at the end yeah but like she [ __ ]
everything up and then he goes on with
his life and he's a baby about how to
seize the moment and if you want
something act on it then don't be
selfish and act on it 20 years from then
I think the director of that movie was
selfish for being involved in that movie
it was a bad movie anyways are we gonna
finish this game Jillian oh yeah what
game we're playing Dead or Alive
did you ever play dead or alive on Xbox
because that was like better than Mortal
Kombat I'll say it it's better than on
Xbox it was a combat game better than
Mortal Kombat really yeah it was like
the two on you know that type of game
where you could duel each other like on
you know you fight yes but the
characters the moves the stages
everything was better than Mortal Kombat
I'll say it okay I'm having their
opinion unpopular opinion why cuz Mortal
Kombat was more
it's always been more popular I love
dead or alive dead or alive alright
let's begin with Rosa Parks dead how old
and when wait Rosa Parks where as the
parks sure I'm not gonna answer that
don't whisper at me no um she's Rosa
Parks is alive how old is she live
87 she is dead she died in 2005 I'm so
sorry she was 92 dang it okay okay move
on yeah sorry Tina Turner do you know
who that is
Tina Turner who's Tina Turner she was uh
she was the one in there that thing what
did she do for a ladies this thing
mm-hmm you think actually is Tina Turner
she's dead when did she die an old she's
not in 2004 at age 66 she live 77
this is worse she's worse than celebrity
why I feel like if I get this wrong I
disrespect that there's no no all right
we're all on the same page it's all in
good fun
the page the 60d Joseph Stalin that stop
eating chips boy if you don't don't put
it in your mouth don't ah door ah ah
[Music]
Joseph Stalin dead or alive from died at
66 and 1989 he died 1953 he was 74
that's close again
Steven Spielberg arrived still creating
bangers dropping are you gonna tell me
how old he's 68 damn he's 69 great yes
good guess
all right the Patrick Swayze alive 62
she died in 2009 1957 I mean we wish but
it's okay it's okay
all right beats okay it's okay all right
all right all right Helen Keller she did
she just say it like that
she said she's dead Louisa said she's
okay she's dead when did she die in hold
that she died at 70 70 in 1999 she died
in 1968 57 let's do the math she would
have been 70 in 1989 mmm-hmm either way
our IP John Travolta alive he's 60 is
that the end of that and yeah he's 62
oh that's really good cuz we're Queen
Elizabeth the second alive 90 you're
exactly right
why am I getting that one right
ridiculous
a lot she's 97 kinda crush in this game
right yeah you how many of you gotten
exactly right three I think three take
four I got I got this one who else did I
get ready to you remember I got uh no
I've actually just blacked out this yeah
you guys know I did remember until you
told the synopsis of stuck on you and
then I think a delve into the best part
of the podcast wow I hate you Wow I'm
stuck on you
imagine we're stuck together that'd be
[ __ ] weird
basically oh sweet Oh Amy mm-hmm just
break my wrist I love you sir
Ludwig van Beethoven dead how dead died
in 1899 at age 56 he died in 1827 at age
56 56 bit like what are you looking how
are you getting these how can I be
looking I'm sitting here thinking about
stuck on you looking at a camera what
you see is what you get oh I hate you
Oh God Nicolas Cage alive thank God 64
he's 52 what's the name of that video
Nicolas Cage let me get out of the ghost
cages anger problems we yeah it's like
one of the best videos it's ever it's
like a compilation of him having freak
outs and breaking out I think it's what
it's called he goes cage freak out
compilation camera looking at weight
when the music slows down then he goes
out let's do that one we'll make three
times in the head can we watch it okay
you need to watch it you don't know
we're gonna watch it it's fine we're
gonna watch it Nicolas Cage freak out
conflict it's one of the best no you're
looking at my is just don't look at my
list yes get to the party punches her
[Music]
I wanted to listen the parties just
yells how to get burned how to get
burned how to get burned as I say that
all the time and no one knows I'm
talking about
how do you first this is a great video
but it is it's called Nicholas Cage
freakout montage it only has half a
million views like how why jus gram-gram
movie that videos great movie it's uh
it's 4-minute it's 4/20 yeah yeah and he
just walks up to this woman imposter in
the face so he's walking down a set of
stairs right now just staring at this
older woman like three times that's him
in a bear suit punching another person
are you fine you're down this is
that's it all right I think we just had
the podcast right there you can't get
any better than that guys quality cinema
really go go look up that video it is
one of the best things among among the
ranks of step on her stuck on him it's
really no yeah it is hit but anyways yes
Nicolas Cage he's alive is alive and
well
what is he well is anyone well Walt
Disney dad died at 71 in 1999 she died
in 1966 he was 65 alright be alright be
okay Julian Whoopi Goldberg dead or
alive alive currently on the view or did
she leave how do you know that trust me
I've seen my fair share of view videos
oh okay
I look those up how old is she when I
want to get angry about stuff I just
like watch the viewer light I can do
anything
how old is she eight seventy she's 60
look good gifts alright Olivia
newton-john
Dead or Alive what she's 65 do you know
what that is
she's alive and she's 65 who is Olivia
newton-john is not what I signed up for
who's Olivia newton-john Adam Jones wife
she is not that like super wrong no I
mean it makes sense bedrooms are not
Elton John's daughter
no she is not Elton John's mom she later
on drunk she is not related tell John I
don't know who she is
have you ever seen the movie Grease oh
that yes she's the girl sandy sandy
owned away that's
oh that's so great wait is he dead you
already guessed it now that you know she
is is she dead or alive how old is she
71 she is alive she is 68 on a way so
great for her it's so good an
accomplished life I love that movie hmm
okay Ernest Hemingway Dead or Alive
dead died at 73 in 1989
why is everyone dying in 1989 bad year
for people just that couldn't quite make
it to that millennial um that's terrible
now he died in 1961 he was 61 over oh he
was 61 mm what are you doing what are
you doing
Ruby you just put me on DS over as I all
right Julian is Michael Kors Dead or
Alive
oh why don't you tell everyone who
Michael Kors is he's a former judge on
Project Runway and that's about it you
liked Michael Kors though I did I liked
Tim Gunn way better yeah we know you
like genuinely liked him gun no I like
loved Tim Gunn like I want him to be my
dad I know everybody does um
tell us how you feel about Zac Posen uh
not the biggest fan not the biggest fan
I'm not the biggest fan although now
that we watched Project Runway all-stars
I get that as much as I may not like him
at times he is a good judge he is a good
judge ah you get mad at him he gets a
little [ __ ] sometimes and I think he
does it just to be the [ __ ] judge like
he's trying so hard to be that guy when
it's like alright pose and calm down
you're posing a little bit shots-fired
unhooks Mike drops
Sylvester Stallone glove how old is 60
no 72 he's 70
very close Coco Chanel what is that what
is that Coco Chanel like Chanel from
ridiculousness oh my god what is car you
talking about chanel west coast
yeah no who's what's Coco Chanel do you
know like why don't you let's just you
narrate your reasoning Chucky
all around said Coco which isn't selling
a name and then chanel is the name of
the brand Chanel is that associated with
this keep going figured I don't you know
started the brand Chanel she died back
in 1999 when everyone else died guess a
real year you can't keep guessing the
same years again no no we're in the
robot doesn't stipulate I can't
repeatedly guess 9999 she died you're
right though she did she started Coco
she got started Chanel okay like you're
different you know so you're saying that
she's dead she died and I say then how
old is she
68 she died in 1971 which is not 1999
and she was 87 okay this is a good long
life accomplished some good stuff I will
guess that someone died 99 and it will
be correct there's only three left on
this list Boyd OJ Simpson dead or alive
um he's alive he's alive he's alive he's
58 he's 69 buh-buh-buh-buh-buh man but
he's alive yeah all right Edgar Allan
Poe deader The Raven that's hate to love
that poem okay I love The Simpsons
episode where they reenact the Raven
where I was one of their Halloween
specials I gotta be honest my only time
as a kid really interested in The
Simpsons was when they did the Halloween
specials cuz they were actually good oh
yeah great um Edgar Allen Poe's is dead
he died in 1999 when he was stole 78
sorry guess a--really er come on
okay 1984 he died in 18-49 and he was 40
I say 18 1984 I meant 1884 18-49 1848
all right this is the last one Kareem
abdul-jabbar dead or alive cream do you
know him yeah of course in the past but
know him personally
Oh Kareem good he's a lot how old is it
jeez 54 he's 69 he also got a Medal of
Freedom the other day from President
Obama Torrey was he like lean back
really funny
to Kareem with a hook that's right you
did pretty good
I'm not gonna lie you did much better
than I thought you were gonna I also
guessed a few exactly correct that's
kind of insane so I guess the moral of
this podcast is that we all should just
go watch stuck on you right now if we
don't we should know you always do we
won't watch it right now
what we'll do is we'll ask fitting fem
when you guys want to have a live
viewing party we will live tweet step on
you normally I am not agreeing to live
tweeting I'm not
you're like I'm meeting Scott oh sorry
we're going to both um be we're gonna
live-tweet it and you guys are going to
watch it at the same time we do so we'll
all watch a long and live tweet be a
weekly weekly thing oh no in fact I
think in 2016 we're canceling the
podcast and every Monday instead we're
all gonna live-tweet stuck on you every
week
no okay we have to watch her at least
once
no and when we watch it I will have
tweet it no no like I don't even care
what you say that's happening I'm
watching stuck on you and I'm going to
live tweet it in fact I can't believe I
haven't live tweet it before such a good
movie to live tweet I'm not here for any
of this I'm gonna live to be second you
guys let me know when you wanna live
tweet start on you I don't want I'll do
it anyways I'm not being part of a gang
a meet-up this weekend and instead of me
meeting you guys I'm just gonna go to a
movie theater watch stuck on you and
I'll be there
that's my Meetup you're gonna have a
hard time convincing a movie theater to
screen stuck on you I know a movie
theater that are big fans of Matt Damon
which ones that the cinema hark that's
not a place that is not a place there is
a 40th Street this is Los Angeles
there's a 40th Street yeah where is it
downtown
mm-hmm downtown you know maybe there is
but no thank you guys for watching
another week in the podcast ah you're
welcome
hey so much [ __ ] this whole time 1999
and stuck on you know what someone
[ __ ] died in 99 and rest in peace to
them because they died for a good reason
at least not to say that no one else in
this podcast everybody oh my god alright
we gotta end this
what because it's so much it's so fun
know those ones are mine don't put those
ones on your head
alright in this one this one's yours the
one on my head we love you guys we love
you ding fan thank you scissors Thank
You naturebox Thank You Mia
so go check out the sponsors links in
the description as always ears are the
best we'll see you guys next week for
another Jenna and Julia podcast thank
you for putting all of my underwear on
your head
bye guys bye bye